this video is made possible by morning
brew morning brew is an email newsletter
sent out every weekday morning you'll
wake up with the most relevant curated
and informative business news from Wall
Street to Silicon Valley flip it right
here inbox morning brew it cuts through
the clutter of business news providing a
quick and high-quality newsletter if you
like what we do here at visual politic
for politics you know I love what
morning brew do for business
I've been subscribed for a few months
now and the short pieces that come into
my inbox every day they're genuinely
interesting this is not an easy feat but
morning brew absolutely deliver the best
stuff whether you want to learn about
startup news from Silicon Valley or
investment news from Wall Street morning
brew they're very covered and it's quick
and easy to read with a cup of coffee in
the morning or maybe on your commute
whatever you prefer pick the link in the
description below to sign up to morning
brewed calm and get the most informative
and witty business news that are around
and let's get into today's video
[Music]
religion and politics always go together
in the Arabian Peninsula the birthplace
of Islam
every year over two million Muslim
pilgrims go to Saudi Arabia to visit
Mecca
[Music]
and in neighboring Abu Dhabi you will
find the most modern architecture
combined with the most ancient
traditions in this part of the planet
Islam is the law nonetheless what if I
tell you that this area of the planet is
the one with the fastest-growing
Christian population really not kidding
here while Europe is carrying less and
less about the Catholic Church here at
the core of the Islamic world we have
the fastest growing Catholic population
I'll tell my practice yep oh boy so how
is that even possible
what enough happened to make Pope
Francis make an official visit to Abu
Dhabi times are a-changing or maybe not
so much in this video we're going to
tell you that story
[Applause]
it doesn't matter if you're Catholic or
not everybody has heard of the Pope and
Pope Francis has the most followers in
the most unexpected places
[Music]
because let's be honest here Catholicism
is not having his best moment in either
Europe or Latin America so you might ask
well where are they having a bigger
presence then well that would actually
be the Arabian Peninsula countries like
Saudi Arabia Qatar and the United Arab
Emirates have more and more Catholics
and I know you're thinking I mean how is
that even possible I mean we probably
all know that Qatar and the United Arab
Emirates have allowed Catholics to build
their own churches but just look at the
Abu Dhabi Cathedral
[Music]
notice anything funny about it well
there aren't no crosses whatsoever the
truth is in this country you can go to
mass but you can't evangelize and if
you're a Muslim and you happen to
convert to Christianity watch out
because that's a crime as you can
imagine the growth of Catholicism in
this part of the world is explained by
one word and pretty much one word only
and that's immigration if you've been
following this channel for a while you
already know that the our rich Arabian
monarchies have more immigrants than
they do locals in places like Qatar in
the UAE the foreign-born population
makes up more than 80% of the total and
of course most of those immigrants
they're Muslim they come from countries
like Bangladesh and Pakistan but you
also have a lot of Americans and a lot
of Filipinos who are Catholic and this
explains news like this
they will visit Pope Francis lands in
Abu Dhabi for historic first golf trip
yep you heard that right for the first
time in history a pope has visited the
arabian peninsula and this was not a
small visit more than a hundred and
eighty thousand people attended his mass
to put this in context that's more than
twice the number of people who went to
his latest mass in chile a catholic
country in other words catholicism is a
bigger deal than you'd expect in arab
countries so now you might be wondering
well why did the abu dhabi authorities
allow such an event in their country why
did the pope get to go there i mean i
mean was this a strategic move what does
Pope Francis want to achieve with this
well today we're going to answer all of
those questions but before we do let's
take a look back at the history
[ __ ] non verba Pope Francis is the
leader of three organizations at the
same time on the one hand he is the head
of the Catholic Church
that is a religious role that we're not
going to get into because this is a
channel about politics and not religion
but do not worry because the Pope has
two other political drops first he's the
head of the world's smallest state
Vatican City and on top of that he's
also the head of the Holy See and oh boy
Vatican City might be a really tiny
nation but the diplomatic influence of
the Holy See is really big
they have embassies in almost all of the
world's countries and they've played a
major role throughout history for
example Pope John Paul the second was a
key player in the fight against
communism in both Poland and in the
Soviet Union and he also lobbied against
the invasion of Iraq
[Music]
his successor benefit the sixteenth was
far less political his legacy focused on
theology and philosophical essays the
current Pope Pope Francis he's far more
political than the other two then this
is why he's quite circumcircle
to son he's an evil communist tear
others he is the champion of dignity and
human rights he's a man who speaks out
clearly against capitalism
Pope Francis on economic inequality such
an economy kills if Jesus Christ liked
to talk in parables Pope Francis likes a
more straightforward style look at its
tough words - Donald Trump Donald Trump
is quote not Christian if he wants to
build a border wall but as they say in
Latin factor non verba which means acts
not words if we look at the facts we
discover a totally different pipe
actually he has more in common with
Donald Trump than we might think
if Trump summarized his political views
with the motto America first we can
summarize Pope Francis's views as
Catholic first this doesn't sound very
spiritual but we could compare the
Catholic Church to a multinational
corporation with residences all over the
world in this light catholicism is
losing ground in their traditional
markets the number of believers in
Europe is getting smaller and smaller
and in Latin America they're in fierce
competition with the evangelical
churches so the new Vatican
Administrative Board they've got a clear
strategy find new markets one of those
markets is China for decades Catholicism
was forbidden that but as you know the
Chinese Communist Party they're very
creative so instead of fully banning
religion what they did was create a fake
copy of Catholicism it's a religion
that's the same in every way to the real
thing but there's one exception bishops
were not appointed by the Vatican but by
the Communist Party and of course those
Catholics who kept their loyalty to the
Pope of Rome they were sent to
concentration camps where they were
tortured and even worse they had their
organs removed for the Chinese
transplant system
in the situation a pope like john paul
ii would have surely adopted a
confrontational position but Pope
Francis knows how to apply the part of
the deal better than Donald Trump
himself so well what did he do well this
is where the Chinese transplant system
comes into play for years China has been
taking organs from political prisoners
for their transplants this is called
organ harvesting as you can imagine
there is all kinds of pressure from
international organizations across the
world to stop this massacre meanwhile
China denies all of the accusations
despite all of the evidence that shows
otherwise they even have a doctor who
tries to go to all of the international
conferences to pitch the official
Chinese narrative no country accepts him
as a speaker of course because they
don't want to listen to his propaganda
no country that is except of a Vatican
the Vatican was the first and only
country outside of China that allowed
this doctor do you participate in an
events and self his story he was able to
pitch the peerless advantages of the
Chinese Transplant system to the whole
world the one system that miraculously
confined organs in just a matter of days
a system that of course meets all of the
human bright standards and all the last
stuff because well I mean when is China
ever exploited human rights before
everybody knows that the Chinese
Communist Party is the biggest fan of
democracy human rights and all of that
jolly good stuff right look needless to
say this Vatican conference it raised a
lot of criticism all over the world but
just a couple of months later Pope
Francis in your new Answers
[Music]
China and Vatican Beach deal and
appointment of Bishops there you go man
just one diplomatic gamble and boom the
Catholic Church now it's got 12 million
more followers with listen Lane they've
already compensated for the lack of new
converts in a country like Spain so
where does that go now well exactly
that's the Arab world
what Benedict the sixteenth openly
criticized Islam Pope Francis has made a
dramatic shift for example do you
remember the Charlie Hebdo terrorist
attacks all of the world leaders were
condemning them without reservation
birds in this situation the normally
straight talk in Francis he turned to
parables for once
Canton saw other people's faith for
example if dr. gooseberry says a bad
word against my mother he can expect me
to punch him in the face this is normal
Pope Francis it's a big statement isn't
it but the goodwill gestures towards
Islam they do not stop here here's
another example
[Music]
in this picture we can see Pope Francis
in the grand Imam of al-azhar one of the
biggest representatives of Sunni Islam
they are together calling upon everybody
to build a more tolerant world with less
violence and imma be wondering well why
this strategy what does the Pope want to
achieve here well let's have a look
shall we
tolerant slavery Pope Francis is
Argentinian of Italian descent his
family were immigrants who came to
Argentina looking for a better life and
you know where we have a lot of
immigrants now
well yeah once again that's the Arabian
Peninsula
[Music]
but not all of those immigrants are born
equal cynical as it sounds we should
make a distinction on the one hand you
have the expats and on the other hand
you have the immigrants an expat might
be an American who comes to Abu Dhabi to
work for ExxonMobil with a six-figure
salary
[Music]
and immigrants on the other hand is a
Filipino who shares a room with 10 other
people works 12-hour shifts and has a
miserable salary most of these
immigrants they work in construction
north a clean houses their families are
usually back in their country of origin
and they send the money regularly many
of you might be thinking right now well
ok Simon but don't exaggerate if they
don't like their working conditions they
can always go home right well actually
it's not that easy you see here in the
Arabian Peninsula there's a system
called the Kafala
according to Kafala immigrants are
linked to a local called the patron if
you want to change your job you're gonna
ask a patron for permission you want to
work for another company ask your patron
wants to leave the country and go back
to your homeland
well yeah once again you got to check
with your patron and if you don't get
that permission and you've got to keep
living in the country essentially
working as a slave so well in the United
Arab Emirates alone there are more than
1 million Catholics who live under these
conditions most of them come from the
Philippines and some parts of India and
is you can imagine in such a desperate
situation many people stick to their
faith more than ever nevertheless
despite these slave-like conditions
these workers are crucial to the economy
who else is going to build the
skyscrapers
in other words building a cathedral in
Abu Dhabi is a cheap way to keep these
workers moderately happy they might be
exploited but at least they've got a
place to pray and he might now be
wondering well how is it possible that
the authorities of these countries being
such Islamic hardliners would allow them
to build a cathedral well dear viewers
the enemies of Arab monarchies neither
Christians nor Hindus the main enemies
of Arab monarchies saw other Muslims for
example the Muslim Brotherhood
think about it which is more dangerous
for an Emir the Philippine immigrants
praying inside of a Cathedral or the
Muslim Brotherhood who claim no loyalty
to anything other than the Koran the
answer it's pretty obvious
this is why in the UAE they have better
things to do than persecuting Christians
which this is why they're so tolerant
but remember there's that tolerance but
they're also violating their human
rights systematically and this this is
where Pope Francis enters the picture
[Music]
the Pope in Abu Dhabi all right so I can
probably guess what you're thinking it's
okay for them to build a church in Abu
Dhabi but I mean a papal visit there's
sort of a different thing isn't it well
truth be told this is actually great for
Abu Dhabi for one they improved their
outside image all of a sudden a country
that was associated with religious
fanaticism is hosting the leader of
another religion who could say that
they're fanatics now but that's not all
with a little effort Abu Dhabi's
government is given a great gift to
those Catholic immigrants the visit is
good news both for those Filipinos
working for pennies and also the expats
with their six-figure salaries in the
end everyone's happy
[Music]
but the question is what does the Pope
want to achieve with this well think
about it
Pope Francis came here to a place where
evangelizing is forbidden and then he
organized the mother of all masses a
hundred and eighty thousand people and
this amazing cross that you could see
from everywhere in abu-dhabi this is
raising the bar now they've set a big
precedence for a would-be change in Arab
legislation and this explains why the
vicar apostolic in Arabia Paul hinder
said all of these beautiful things about
the governments of the UAE prayed for
the rulers of this country who make it
possible I thank the UAE government for
their generosity not only have they made
this visit possible but have
wholeheartedly given us a venue to
celebrate mass and what about Pope
Francis yes he was all Don Donald Trump
but when it comes to the Abu Dhabi
authorities he didn't have a word to say
about a father or the war in Yemen in
fact this is what he said is there like
a chicken your country is a land that
wants to be a model of coexistence human
Brotherhood and gathering of different
cultures and civilizations after these
gestures it wouldn't be hard to imagine
the United Arab Emirates lifting their
ban on other religions or at least on
Catholicism this would be a giant step
that the church in a market yet to be
tapped so now it's your turn do you
think the Pope is a deal-making genius
off any you should care a little bit
more about you know human rights well
please leave your answer in the comments
section below also visit reconsider
Mediacom the podcasts that provided the
vocals in this episode that were not
mine if you like this video give it a
thumbs up also please visit our
fantastic sponsor morning brew there is
a link to them below and as always I'll
see you next time and if you want to
learn more about politics and hear even
more of my lovely voice you can join us
at reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
[Music]